now a one-week extension to a truce has
been agreed in principle by Sudan's Army
Chief and the leader of the paramilitary
rapid support forces the announcement
was made by South Sudan's foreign
Ministry fighting in the past few days
has intensified in onderman and the
neighborhood of Bari rival Tides have
been battling for control of the
presidential Palace and Khartoum
International Airport military
airstrikes have also hit paramilitary
positions to the north of the capital in
Bari more people continue to flee Sudan
as the humanitarian situation worsens
Heber Morgan reports from cartoons
this is the aftermath of an airstrike by
Sudanese Army fighter jets on supposed
positions of the paramilitary rapid
support forces bahri has been the focus
of fighting in recent days with the two
sides trying to gain full control of the
city
it's not just the airstrikes artillery
strikes by the rapid support forces also
hits buildings in parts of Bahari three
weeks of fighting between the rsf and
the Sudanese Army killed hundreds of
people and injured thousands of others
but there are parts of the capital that
were relatively quiet on Tuesday
a queue for bread in South Khartoum
hungry people hoping to take advantage
of a temporary ceasefire that's been
extended by the two wearing sides some
have been waiting for many hours and
worry they'll go home empty-handed
I swear I have been here since three in
the morning so far I have not been able
to get one loaf of bread my children
have not eaten anything since yesterday
and today is almost gone
the U.N is running the humanitarian
crisis in Sudan is turning into what it
calls a full-blown catastrophe and
millions are affected
we are government employees and our
salaries have not been paid most of the
people are now re-prioritizing their
needs they're not even targeting 30
percent of their basic needs we pray
this crisis comes to an end and our
country restores peace and security
fuel in the capital is in short supply
most petrol stations are closed the few
that are open have long queues there is
relief for some who've been unable to
access their savings for more than two
weeks the Central Bank of Sudan says
most of its branches outside the capital
have reopened its reassured Savers that
despite looting their deposits are safe
so far we've not faced any problems
clients are handling their accounts cash
is flowing and people are buying and
selling the situation was difficult in
the early days of the conflict but now
everything is back to normal
but people trapped in the areas of bahri
and East Nile north of the capital
Khartoum are bracing for more airstrikes
and explosions as the Army and the rapid
support forces battle for control of
Sudan at the expense of its people Hiba
Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum
from South Sudan's capital Juba
haramatasa has more on that announcement
of a seven-day extension to the truce
South Sudan's Foreign Affairs Ministry
released a statement saying that
President saw the Kia has spoken to
warning sites in Sudan and this is what
was agreed in principle we asked that
from first of May to 11 of May that
there should be a ceasefire observed by
the two parties he has talked to both of
them to Jordan and to himiti and both of
them are greatly principle he also asked
specifically for the two to names the
representative for the talk so that we
have a pre discussion a free talk
because War
cannot be earned unless people talked so
he has prevailed and appealed to them he
stress that it is important that these
seven days
there's a need for general for hunt and
himiti to name the representative to the
top the third one is a definite date
that they should agreed on the date that
this particular talk will comment some
of the people leaving Sudan are coming
conflict caught up got us with a
surprise and this is why when these
people came in
we were unable to intervene on time
because the number was very big the
number were very big even if we rush we
would have not actually been able to do
sufficient work as we are now trying to
do most people arriving are from South
Sudan they'll probably end up staying
with family and friends foreigners who
work with their embassies to go back
home those who have nowhere else to go
will probably end up staying in camps
for internally displaced people
harumatasa Al jazera
well the United Nations says more than a
hundred thousand people have fled Sudan
since heavy fighting broke out on April
15. Ahmed Idris reports from gangur near
the child Sudan border where thousands
of refugees from the Darfur region have
been arriving
they keep coming any way they can
the United Nations High Commissioner for
Refugee says an average of 100 people
are registered here every day
all of them from therefore fleeing
attacks from ethnic militias
Suleiman Ibrahim Abdullah just arrived
with his family at this informal Camp of
4 000.
not minding that even residents of the
capital aren't faring much better all he
cares about now is how and where his
family finds food and shelter
blind and helplessly mine arrived five
days ago with his life family hoping
also to find food shelter and some peace
so far he says he's found none
we have had no food and no clean water
since we arrived here five days ago
may be preoccupied with safety and
Welfare of the family
but for the young ones anytime is
Amusement time
from tendulki to gunguru and other
border communities the mass migration to
child is fueled by violence and threats
of it from ethnic militias and rebel
groups
a weakened central government in hartum
has given ethnic militias the
opportunity to consolidate their
positions especially in regions like
Darfur and this is forcing thousands
from Minority tribes to flee across the
border into Chad
while some refugees want to go back home
as soon as security improves some say
they plan to make their move to Chad
permanent
the United Nations wounds that the
unfolding crisis in Sudan can plunge the
entire region into a deeper crisis
something Chad government says it's
taking seriously
we've asked all security personnel and
officials to be on alert and sensitize
the civilian population too
that is crucial for Chad whose piece is
also fragile
Ahmed Idris
Sudan border